is the function given below continuous
slash differentiable at x equals three
and they've defined it piecewise and we
have some choices continuous not
differentiable differentiable not
continuous both continuous and
differentiable neither continuous nor
differentiable now one of these we can
knock out right from the get-go it you
cannot in order to be differentiable you
need to be continuous there so you
cannot have differentiable but not
continuous so let's just rule that one
out and now let's think about continuity
so let's first think about continuity
and frankly if it isn't continuous then
it's not going to be differentiable so
let's think about it a little bit
so
in order to be continuous f of i'm just
in a darker color f of 3
needs to be equal to the limit
of f of x as x approaches 3. now what is
f of 3
well see we fall into this category this
case right over here because x is equal
to 3. so 6 times 3 is 18 minus 9 is 9.
so this is 9. so the limit of f of x is
x approaches 3 needs to be equal to 9.
so let's first think about the limit
as we approach from the left hand side
the limit as x approaches 3
x approaches 3 from the left hand side
of f x
well when x is less than 3 we fall in
into this case so f of x is just going
to be equal to
x
squared
and so
this is defined and continuous for all
real numbers so we can just substitute
the 3 in there so this is going to be
equal to 9.
now what's the limit
of as we approach 3 from the right-hand
side of f of x
well as we approach from the right this
one right over here is
f of x is equal to 6x minus 9. so we
just write 6x minus 9. and once again 6x
minus 9 is defined and continuous for
all real numbers so we could just pop a
3 in there and you get 18 minus 9 well
this is also equal to 9. so the right
and left hand the left and right hand
limits both
equal 9 which is equal to the value of
the function there so it is definitely
continuous so we can rule out
we can rule out this choice right over
there
and now let's think about
differentiability
so in order to be differentiable
so
differentiable
i'll just differentiable
in order to be differentiable the limit
as x approaches 3
of f of x
minus f of 3
over x minus 3 needs to exist so see if
we can evaluate this
so first of all we know what f of 3 is f
of 3 we've already evaluated this this
is going to be 9. and let's see if we
can evaluate this limit or let's see
what this the limit is as we approach
from the left-hand side and the
right-hand side and if they're
approaching the same thing then we know
that the slip then that same thing that
they're approaching is the limit so
let's first think about the limit as x
approaches 3 from the left-hand side so
it's over x minus 3 and we have f of x
minus 9. but as we approach from the
left hand side this is f of x as x is
less than 3 f of x is equal to x squared
so this would be instead of f of x minus
9 i'll write x squared minus 9. and x
squared minus 9 this is a difference of
squares so this is x plus 3 times x
minus 3
x plus 3 times x
minus 3.
and
so these would cancel out we can say
that this equivalent to x plus 3 as long
as x does not equal 3. that's okay
because we're approaching from the left
and as we approach from the left well x
plus 3 is is defined for all real
numbers it's continuous for all real
numbers so we can just substitute the 3
in there so we could we would get a 6.
so now let's try to evaluate the limit
as we approach from the right hand side
so once again it's f of x but as we
approach from the right hand side f of x
is 6 x minus 9. that's our f of x
and then we have minus f of 3 which is
9. so it's 6 x minus 18. 6x
minus 18. well that's the same thing as
6 times x minus 3. and as we approach
from the right well that's just going to
be equal to
that's just going to be equal to 6.
so it looks like
our our derivative exists there and it
is equal the limit as x approaches 3 of
all of this business is equal to 6
because the limit as we approach from
the left and the right is also equal to
6. so this looks like we are both
continuous and
both continuous and differentiable